tim
have you watched uh tiger's documentary
i have not seen him yesterday
so i think you'll get a kick out of it
if you watch a documentary so
um i watch the documentary and i'm
sitting there saying wow
you know the role his father played
in tiger's life i don't know if tiger's
tiger without the father
you sit there and you think about
something from two years old so what if
your dad's like
if if tiger's my kid would tiger be
tiger because of golf probably not i'm
not a golf guy so
you sit there and you think about some
of these guys that get at the level that
they get
you know how the mom pushed you know
people think dad was a disciplinarian
tiger's mom was a discipline one mom
that was a little bit more
easy going you think about michael the
story with his that were the one part in
the last stance he says
you know his dad's like oh you know why
don't you just go out there and do what
you're doing you know i'm going to go
here with your brother
and his dad was kind of a challenging
play some mind games with him and he
talked about in the last dance right and
michael said
when you're going through it it's very
difficult it's torture because you don't
know what's really happening to you
when someone's challenging you i don't
know the story about kobe who was
obviously his father played and i
have that idea but i don't know who you
know
the role dad played
in a mathematical formula you'll hear
you know uh
pythagorean theorem if you take this and
you take you take this equals this right
if you want to make a
bomb or if you want to make an explosive
you're in a military your navy seal if
you take this you command it with this
you command it with this eddy cools
an explosive product that you're
producing right if you want to make a
milkshake you know you take this you
combine this everything has a recipe
there's a recipe to the madness
specifically to the madness not all the
other stuff
if you were to take the recipe of a
guy like a tiger or a kobe or a jordan
i'm specifically talking about those who
are
not one of the best i'm talking about
the goat league we're talking about
is there a weird family member
that psychologically mess with you a
little bit to challenge you
is there a massive setback in life with
a ton of pain
is it someone you love so much that you
want to make proud
is it a massive public humiliation you
know where somebody embarrassed you
is it is it the dna of the individual
because the same four kids could be from
the same family but only one of them
ends up becoming you have the same
pretty much structure how do you not
come out of it and all four what would
you say from your experience and i don't
even know if you have the answer to this
but what would you say from my
experiences
the one percent of the one percent that
people read about people write about
people watch
documentaries about what separates those
guys everything that you mentioned
everything that he meant obviously
listen
you're not going to be a great if you
don't have the genetics to be a great
athlete no matter how much training you
do you're just never going to be
you're never going to be able to reach
that level all right
that's that has a thing that that pays
important
that an important role picking the
picking the rights picking the right
sport
you have to ha there's always been an
individual that's held you accountable
when you're young it could be a parent
it could be somebody that's like really
doesn't let you
doesn't let you get away with things
that
that put that pushes you that forces you
to do things you look at the williams
sisters from tennis they're
you know no question yeah yeah there's
there's al all there's always that
there's always that individual yes
you've gone through some adversity
there's something there that you just
that you that you rem
that you remember and you just like that
becomes you that's
that's your fuel that's like something
that
you don't need anybody else to light
that fire that's that's
what that's what you're that's what
you're made of and how you handle that
because a lot of individuals when they
go through that
when they go through that challenge they
go through that disappointment
other people make it too easy for them
you know because our job as parents our
job as individuals it is the comfort
it is the comfort all right
in order to see winning in all its glory
it wants to see you suffer
it wants to know what you're made of so
if you like this sort of short clip from
an interview i did click over here to
watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]